[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
pour ce nouveau numéro de presse
on est le 11 novembre jour férié prenait
quand même en direct on est là on est
alors le plus beau de bras
[Musique]
bien pratique
est ce que dans la drôme il laissait les
bras en l'air
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
manninger donc voilà il ya un
chroniqueur masqué est ce que vous avez
une idée de chroniqueurs masqué qui est
le chroniqueur masques et chroniqueur
pas ce qu'est ce que ça va oui six
indices sur la voie ça n'a pas trop
chaud samaras
[Musique]
[Rires]
peut-être mais mature 20e avec des
métiers concernés du bonheur aux gens
la générosité jusqu'à lui voit dans
l'année
c'était leurs proches de à 19 heures
c'est l'inversé de et du jeune fille non
et puis tu prends un verre avec eux
étudient la cud du partage la
communication c'est ça qui est beau
merci pour toi qui met au micro merci à
toi ça c'est un silo de quatre couleurs
c'est un cadeau de clara morgane
le bic le célèbre beat ça m'a fait très
plaisir